[Music]
w
[Applause]
e
[Music]
w
hey everyone welcome to gamespot's live
stream of bully Scholarship Edition uh
this was just added as an backwards
compatible title on the Xbox one earlier
today like a matter of hours ago um bit
of an unexpected announcement from
Rockstar but a really great excuse to go
back and play arguably one of their
better games kind of an underappreciated
but never forgotten entry in Rockstar's
like famous open world game catalog it
is my personal favorite Rockstar really
over Red Dead over any of the GTA yeah
there's something about the the tone and
the setting of this game that I think is
like so brilliant and that you don't see
that often that I think still holds a
special place in my heart we were
talking about this before the stream
started that this is a rare example of a
game that's kind of like a Coming of Age
story and like set and like starring
teenagers like tot life is strange is
another game that that does that but
it's hard to think of too many others I
would assume that's part of why this
resonates with so many people but I love
this game as well I haven't played it in
about 10 years so uh you know I remember
quite a bit I think about Jimmy Hopkins
and Borth Academy but we we'll find out
yeah I might I might actually be way
worse at this than I than I think I am
we'll we'll see but I have subtitles
turned on so if you want to ignore us
and just you know read what's happening
instead that's totally fine yeah we're
going to be streaming for approximately
an hour so we won't get too far into the
game but we're going to mess around and
kind of show you guys what it's all
about to say something subtitles are not
on thanks a lot Xbox wow yeah cuz you
checked you I turned them yeah I turned
them on and I restarted you told me
never to talk to strangers like I said
before Jimmy you have any questions in
the chat I will be looking at the chat
so uh I do like the voice acting though
so like it's pretty Jimmy does a really
good
job also seeing this intro makes me
really appreciate how far we've come
visually in games I love it that you're
twice as old as my grandfather and
you're fat and B that's enough I've had
it with you you little
brat yeah Jimmy's great God I the music
the music in this game it's probably one
of my favorite it's like Harry Potter s
practically it's got this kind of like
mysterious Vibe right suddenly he
realizes I can't believe you you little
monster we'll deal with you when we get
back from our honeymoon next year so
please post in the comments who you
think the real bully is in this game
because arguably Jimmy is the good guy
right like he's not the bully he's he's
like bullying the bullies he's the Robin
Hood of Bor academ got like so much
controver cuz you know obviously back in
the day and even maybe now still even
like you know rockar was like oh no
they're the the murder simulators right
and this one's like and now they're
making kid bully simulators and you're
like like they're encouraging kids to
bully each other exactly and you're like
actually like you're kind of you can do
that in this game but for the most part
you're like helping everyone yeah if you
follow the missions pretty much every
mission is like hey kid I need something
please help me out and he's like all
right I'll get you out of this sticky
situation but you owe me a favor and
it's like I don't know it's
it's not too mean spirited or anything
and the few the few bad things you do
are like not like everyone else is so
much worse yeah I think we can all agree
that the adults in this game are Far and
Away the worst people yeah also real
quick I love that the loading screens
are these images of the different
characters it's a great way to like
subtly introduce and and characterize
the sort of main mission givers in the
game without really explicitly telling
you I like the little comic book and the
comic book background that's pretty NE
it's such a cool touch like Rockstar is
so good at details like that just those
little things that draw you into the
experience and kind of like give you
something to love a lot of people in the
chat are mentioning that uh what is
wrong with you the um
XBox um version that like oh sorry for
PS4 players oh you can't play this game
you actually can play this game on ps4
it is available as a digital download
believe though it is the original PS2
version you'll be very happy not the
remastered version that this one is
schar
but it is possible actually play a game
on your
PS this looks better than PS2 quality
though the head is Youk adjust our in
his study okay his study is over there
Boys by the way everyone feel free to
let us know if the levels are off or
anything like that we can make
adjustments and we are going to be
keeping an eye on the chat both in uh
YouTube and twitch and on site
brilliant you all getting a really nice
view of Jean Luke's
arm SL beard uh
mhm it's going well it's going well so
far I think it's fine man I think people
are going to be focused on the game May
probably it's fine everything's fine
right guys let us know in the chat that
everything's fine like really like off
camera all right it still damn you know
this actually still looks pretty good I
mean yes and
no okay actually you know what the
textures in the ground are better than I
would expect and like yeah it's it looks
it doesn't quite have the blurriness
that I expected but granted this is also
a HD update yeah well to be clear so we
are playing like the 360 version of the
game like it's just backwards compatible
which in the case of a digital download
means like it just now works on Xbox one
they didn't do anything to it it's just
you're now able to fire it up on an Xbox
one yeah I'm going to invert the
controls cuz I'm one of these people I
remember being so happy when this came
out because um I never had a PS2 so um I
could only ever play the game at a
friend's house yeah I did a lot of that
I did with Tony Hawk actually cuz I
didn't have a PS1 when the original Tony
Hawk came out so this game finally came
out on on um you know PS4 and or PS3 and
Xbox 360 and PC I was like yes I can
finally like sit down and play it on my
own although I remember those ports also
having a lot of bugs weird is yeah I
mean we we've come a long way in games
in general it's the world is less blurry
and less buggy the best
ports I think rockstars also come a long
way with can I fight these guys already
like they want to fight me
oh yeah let's do it just get right into
it I probably shouldn't have punched
both of them oh oh the prefix I forgot
about this run okay I don't want to get
busted this early what's the sprint
button there we go okay bye oh I love
that music it's like the 70 like yeah
yeah yeah it's a total like dirty hairy
uh like car chase like everyone's like
running two their cars before the car
chase
starts you'll be PR to the map no I
won't goob in the chat what's up dude oh
no we've been busted what did I fail I
wasn't even on a mission yet I forgot
that they follow you inside see I said
it's been 10
years when you're knocked out you fail
your task oh it literally just starts me
back here all right I'm just going to go
in without fighting anybody this time
let's get to
the fart back oh man please post your
favorite adolescent insult in the
comments fart bag is number one so far
that's a pretty good one yeah there's a
really fun
like juvenile humor to it all where like
they're not swearing yeah it's like
slightly subversive and slightly snarky
but all kind of like tongue and cheek in
this really clever way I mean it's
Rockstar's trademark humor this is kind
of what they're known for and it works
so well in like a pretentious setting
like bull worth that is that exists to
be sazed right I hate you wow that's
that was that's aggressive pretty wow
you've been here for like 3 seconds they
really uh they're not a welcoming bunch
are they Jimmy he's got a face that only
a mother could Love's got a punchable
face got a maybe a little punchable face
I actually I like Jimmy there there's
hello there ma'am look he's such a
polite young man actually one thing I
really like about Rockstar's characters
is how they they do a pretty good job
with their their character designs where
they hin they avoid the stereotypical
video game problems like everyone looks
like a certain way they look beautiful
they look like this a lot of Rockstar
characters look like real people right
you know what I mean yeah maybe more
more as their games got more
sophisticated but yeah this is actually
a good example of like Jimmy you look at
Jimmy and you're like that's not
something you would make your video most
games wouldn't make their character
character I I don't know that Jimmy's
the best example cuz he kind of looks
like every bald Space Marine right I
mean to an extent he looks like the
teenage version of the kid that grows up
to be like I don't know name any shooter
it's a kid space a dude from resistance
any of the dudes from resistance there
sever boys like you at making you
respectable members of our community
here at the love everyone in this oh God
good feeling the dialog is great he's
such a douche immediately just the
douchiest douche to ever douche and he's
got that stupid fish behind him you just
you can't wait to punch this guy goo in
the chat said he almost thought this
would be the iOS version that would have
been a really funny goof if we streamed
the are I do love the term a goof a goof
I love no more than you deserve all
right she's got friend
show and get him properous word of the
day is OB come along boy good for your
for your sat for everyone out there
who's currently living through Prep
School remember you will have a clean
nose literally we will make you wash
your
nose we have nose washing machines here
at bullworth and you will use
them the shiniest noses there's
something so fun about
that um like private new engling private
school environment that I feel like this
particular setting and
like what it invokes is like you don't
get that in like other parts of even
like America and that old creep thinks
he there is
something old world about like New
England it's I mean it's one of the few
places in the country that I've visited
that there's like a tangible sense of
history and yeah and institutions like
this kind of in my experience or maybe
in popular media only seem to exist in
the Northeast they all have the same
kind of vibe to them maybe that's just
like the result of media iterating on
itself right like our it's a feedback
loop but um yes scob I am I am getting
over a sickness um he's got the plague
got the plague got everyone else sick no
that's not true totally truey other
people were sick before me but John Luke
made everyone sick definitely look at
that everyone in the office has been
sick at this point Clips through the
stairs when you go down that's wacky
whatever I think Tay Tay blamed Julio I
believe why do people as the as the
originator of the illness oh dudee like
zip your come on man like he will be a
mission Giver later in the game yeah
that guy's got to zip his pants up I
can't remember how much open World stuff
we can do this early on oh yeah
important notti is this will be here so
yeah it's not going to actually give us
anything yet I remember like the game it
takes a at least a little bit before you
get to like um you can actually wander
outside in like the town you get a bike
and there's actually quite a bit to see
on the campus itself but yeah you don't
get the bike and you aren't allowed to
leave while good build up yeah as with
all rock
there's a really fun sense of like time
progression in this game I remember
there there's that really good um
Halloween Mission you late to class
though it's so annoying to have to run
back for class yeah I still kind of want
to just fight people but I'm going to
I'm going to do missions instead okay I
think you got to go to your room uh yeah
where's the so I got to yeah yeah the
boys the boys
oror I think the girls is on the left
boys on the right yep yeah there's the
mission where you have to like do a
panty raid in the Girls D and you like
sneak in the roof guess what time it is
oh hey I do get to fight some people
time for a beat down yeah this is an
aggressive ass place look at his even
his face he's like what the what is
wrong with you people like I'm just
trying
to like Jimmy actually is like STI move
Jimmy stick and move float like a
butterfly he he's kind of that reluctant
in the in the story he's very reluctant
where he's like I just kind of want to
do what I'm just kind of want to be me
he mainly wants to be left alone and
like everyone's constantly harassing him
oh he getting beat go go go ha yeah take
the
hell it's a freaking Mass you got to
humiliate him that how do I humiliate
again oh yeah
okay that's give him the Finish give him
the finisher well you got yeah you got
like you
got there we go Indian burn he had to be
he had to stand up I love that the
finishing moves are like classic
childhood torture things like that
actually Indian Burn's probably uh
very outdated offensive term to use imag
what is the current I have no idea I
feel bad because I honestly don't even
know it that is a large large man break
it up I don't even know what I would
call it young man cuz as a kid I only
ever heard it called an Indian burn but
that's AR sick armb burn bro a come on
thinking about it like that's really
offensive and you probably should not
use
that things have changed a lot it's cool
I'm just going to make up with all the
boys later and it will balance out it'll
be more Hey kid yeah what's it to you
friendly aren't give me a break loser
hey relax friend you're all pent up go
easier they put you on the eyar they did
to me I love the voice actor for Gary
that's fascinating actually that's I
think another thing that Rockstar does
really well they their games are
typically well cast and well acted you
just arrived at the toughest School in
the country and I'm offering to be some
pretty good voices for like kids too
place like this you're going to friends
I would imagine the actors weren't this
age range but they are convincing as
teenagers I think they're they do a
convincing job how about I show you
around someone in the comments it's
snake bur is that a thing we'll call it
snake bur snake bur it does make kind of
sense oh I'm fighting someone again
apparently get a drink from the Soto
machine oh I can I forgot I can sneak oh
yeah there's like stealth in this game
aha there is so much that I've clearly
forgotten about this
game we will watch television the rest
of the stream will just be us watching
static television it'll be pretty
awesome Neo jet Angel says we call a
Chinese burn where he's from so not much
better yeah that's also that's also not
any better dude Jim's got 50 bucks that
is Rich that kid is
Rich I didn't have 50 bucks in high
school actually not in
my hey you can change in your closet oh
that's
right and I have nothing right now right
pajamas hell yeah oh those are some sick
pajamas yeah those are pretty good I
have a feeling that I won't be allowed
into class
so that's literally all I have right
okay bummer school uniform it is Jimmy
fix your collar what are you doing this
is the OC now he pops it he like n not
down oh did I back out without
interface except a yeah except I hit a
it did not like it okay there we go
soone wants to know if the game is still
in 30 frames per second it looks like it
yeah although this isn't the kind of
game where the frame frame rate is
really going to make or break the
ISF here 5 minutes and already people
want me dead even my parents didn't hate
me this I remember py having like a
really sad story lineth it's a dump
great yeah there are several characters
in this game that are like they're more
they're more than they we halfway decent
cuz I'm really bad give up the tough guy
act pal hey man what's your problem well
add primarily but also life do you think
they will ever actually make a sequ
civilization it's been 10 years nothing
so far I mean my my guess would be they
make sequels based on the games that
sold right which is why we've had so
many Grand Theft Autos this game not
sell very well I would imagine it didn't
sell as well as GTA or Red Dead
Redemption I don't have sales numbers I
have no idea but I feel like this was
more of like a beloved cult hit that has
a very passionate but maybe not as large
fan base so it's definitely possible
someday but clearly right now Rockstar's
resources are going directly into red
dead so I know that in interviews
Rockstar has said that
they've never obviously said
yes they've said that they like Bully
and they have a lot for that they would
there there's definitely like interest
within the studio for that as an idea as
far as if they'll actually ever do that
who knows how much power those people
who have interest in it I'm still
waiting on a sequel to their ping pong
game Rockstar table tennis oh look we're
81% done with the game already we
breezing through this damn yeah well we
got another 40 minutes we can do it yeah
now you could stop me seriously I just
want to fight
everyone everyone that everyone that
talks smack trying not to swear uh as I
walk by says uh where do you think the
sequel would be that's a good question
Worth University a college but here's
the thing I would sure college would be
fun
but I think you could still have a lot
of
fun just like setting in a different set
for a school right you know like dude
what if he went to juvie what if he got
sent to Military Academy got even
tougher okay well I mean I I don't know
if it would still start Jimmy that'd be
that would have to but um you know I I
think there's schools in different
settings that for I remember Jimmy it's
not like this game sees Jimmy all the
way through graduation or something let
me show you around
thison wait am I fighting Gary no no no
he's he's showing you around oh that's
so as far as like School simulator you
got bully which is sort of your New
England uh and then you got like Persona
3 and four which is your uh the Persona
series is like your Japanese school
settings yeah you know I've never
actually um I've never actually played a
Persona game Persona 4 uh is one of my
favorite games of all time I love that
game I'm reading the promps cuz I don't
remember how this works either and those
games also are great because they
uh each game also is in a different like
the first game or the third game is very
much in a um like a a major city and
then the second game or the fourth
game's in like a rural environment to
town
so there there's something to be said
about like just by changing the
environment in this game and setting in
like a different part of America you
could there's a lot you could do with
that don't let the prefects see you
break any rules they'll hurt
[Music]
you slowly I love that this is a
mechanic in this game plus I feel like
rock seriously come on game probably do
a lot with like the 10 years of you know
you got kids and their social medias and
their tumblers and Tinder and right like
I feel like there's a lot there's a lot
to Satur eyes the Satur eyes that
Rockstar could could potentially do
pretty
well I'm relearning how this game works
know you're not supposed to be doing
that okay let me run away now let me run
away there we go run
Jimmy hide in the garbage ah yes
spent a lot of time in High School
hiding in garbage
pins haha no one can see me
[Music]
here get away whatever you like being
come on psycho this I just remember
there being like a lot of freedom to
this game and what you could do um yeah
once you get through the opening section
which we are already almost through from
what I remember uh yeah you're pretty
much just left your own devices you do
have to show up for class or the game
will punish you but other than that well
you can hide you can try and hide and
skip class yeah I mean that's true it
still comes back to bite you though it
does it does but there they they give
you that freedom to like there is that
rigid School structure but you can also
Bend those
rules all right I really like that
socializing and apologizing are like
playable mechanics in the game yeah yeah
that's that's really fun as press a to
apologize cuz I remember there's like
the different factions that you want to
like Curry favor with
and um there are characters that you
like grow relationships with over the
game um in a way that that felt
meaningful over time at least um I felt
like it
didn't stolen your chocolate cuz man let
me tell you real bummer we won't be able
to get to it but I remember you could
like go on
dates I I like him just standing there
with the chocolate like the cake like
looking like stupid Chate
like ah man no one will no one will find
me feel
and watch
it I love the ambient dialogue in this
game I'm just a regular kid it's like
all right yeah yeah a lot of good
dialogue what's that say up there uh
nerdy I I think right nerdy for a second
I thought it's like a swastika on the
left I don't think this it's not quite
that kind of game thankfully it doesn't
really get that extreme it's it's pretty
tame overall I believe Gary was a neon
Nazi I'd buy that oh that's a little
love those sound effects absolutely what
it sounds like when you make out with
someone I'll remember this
forever actually kissed her just I mean
I don't feel like he kissed her she kind
of just like grabbed him listen things
happen B Borth is a wild and crazy Place
sometimes you
know just gets out of hand oh the the
lunch lady is great I remember being a
big fan of the lunch lady yeah the lunch
lady is fun Doris I to say time at the
zoo sounds right okay here's the deal
over there we got the Nerds of course
social got your NDS they look pretty
harmless they're actually sneaky
bastards their Turf is the
library and those are the preps doesn't
like
libraries good prep there that one guy
on the left though has like no neck very
observant Jimmy boy but he does have a
pretty sick sweater greasers they think
they're tough classic GRE to look tough
he's got the cigarette in his his ear do
you have any any greasers at your high
school no we had like a couple
rockabilly guys at my school like the
guys who were like kind of into Punk but
then got really into like Johnny Cash
and started wearing like leather jackets
and like slicking their hair and like
starting psycho bellly bands man like
tiger big tiger Army fans never had like
quite that level of of Clicks in in my
school oh really my I had a huge I went
to a huge school so they kind of like we
ended up with pretty big social my
school was pretty small so you
definitely had like social groups that
definitely existed but not quite to that
degree not so well defined yeah um cuz
it was it was such a small school I went
to hey everyone in the comments were you
bullied in high school tell us your
worst or best bullying story or were you
a bully should we fight you let us know
in the comments my friend was actually
telling me about a horrible uh bully
story that happened to him is this going
to be a sad story or an amusing it's
kind of sad kind of I'll I'll tell it uh
I the kill care you don't all right so
he worked at a subway what are you doing
in here and uh all of the other people
who uh worked there a bunch of them to
follow my inst sell drugs in the back of
the subway and actually use like the the
sandwich scale to like weigh their their
their bags of drugs and stuff that's
pretty Brazen but yeah that sounds it
sounds like high school So eventually
they got paranoid that he was going to
knock on them even though he like he's
like no was you know like whatever so
they uh dude chemistry is super easy by
the way constantly kept seeding to their
boss who was never around during their
shift that he was like a really bad
employee who like never did anything and
then the boss was like hey uh we got to
let some people go and he's like I got
to let you go cuz like you don't
actually like work that hard he's like
what are you talking about and he's like
yeah like they were saying that and he's
like dude those guys like sell drugs out
of here and then the boss goes they told
me you would make up a story like that
that they would be selling drugs and uh
I don't believe you and I'm like holy
[__] they like actually said like and
he'll probably say like we've been
selling drugs or something like wow
that's like some movie [__] that's like
I know like that's some reverse
psychology like oh damn that's insane
that's hard to believe that that is a
real thing that happened and then it
worked and then it worked yeah the fact
that it worked I'm just trying to fit in
that's a real bummer for your friends
although In fairness it's like I don't
know crappy High School fast food job I
would imagine he's moved up in the world
since then
I Place full ofies and Maniac not a fun
thing to go through yeah when you're in
high school like suck Jinx
why again my school so small like for
the most part like bowling at least for
me likein I want you to behave uh my
favorite bullying story that I remember
was uh there was a friend's older
brother who was also like a punk rock
dude like none of the in my school I
grew up in La where the cool kids were
all Surfers and so I hung out with the
weird music punk rock kids and we didn't
get along with the Surfers and I
remember one lunch like they were trying
to start [__] I don't remember what the
situation was but at the end when like
the Bell rung we were going our separate
ways and one of the Surfers like threw a
water bottle and my friend's brother's
reaction was to pick up the water bottle
and open it and just start pouring it
over his head and laughing at them ha
like and it was just the craziest
reaction and it was just the most badass
thing I'd seen as like a 14-year-old
that sounds like a movie to me and it
was weird it felt like it it was such a
memorable holy [__] dude what are you
doing this like what is happening yeah
it was intense it was really it was
really cool oh whoops I should have been
playing a mission instead of Davis Got
Away guys what are we going to do now do
I retry the mission or did I just fail
okay there we go that is that is a a
complaint I would definitely have about
the opening of this game is that um if
you just want to get right into like
open world
aspect Mak quite comfortable yeah we're
comfortable here let me let me skip this
uh yeah any good any good bullying
stories in the
comments I not seen any yet I'm
looking come back Davis oh yeah I tap
you I'm sure this looks really funny in
the picture and picture one guy says
uh this is oh that's weird that was a
weird animation glitch uh some like
apparently the in the shower the other
guys peed on me and the teacher did not
care at all that's that's maybe the
weirdest that's that's weird that's
there are several levels of why that
would be traumatizing sorry to hear that
man yeah that's sorry you went to a
school where you had to shower in gym
class I don't know why I would
ever I mean that what's funny comp me to
want to do that to somebody I'm going to
ignore you guys cuz I have to run ah
you're going to have a trail of of dudes
after yeah that's fine that's fine I
just got to get to this guy ah okay now
I have to fight them okay well let me
get in a corner so I can't get flanked
and now I'm going to fight all of you
yeah this is going to be great the nice
thing is that my punches will hit
multiple targets so this is going to
work out just fine I like that the um
spamming the their health is underneath
them on the circle that's oh that's not
going smart UI there
yeah I'm going to get punched from
behind in a second unless this guy goes
down ah
I think the combat in this game is basic
but
satisfying can I end this if I humiliate
one of them ah stop it stop
it there we go they got that's you got
humiliate oh yeah the soda's like a
grenade basically right yeah yeah
there's uh give me your soda yep oh you
got to hurry yeah so you got to throw it
at him to knock him down oh that's right
something and I got a uh we got a
firecracker okay I'll just do that
cuz I don't know what happened to the
soda I had
damn
boom that works and I might still make
it to
class yeah
slingshot I really just want the bike
though someone says uh oh someone in the
chat who I know says I was once drop
kicked into the snow after we got back
from Bowling practice by someone else on
the team not even because I was a bowler
wow like Bully uh bowling kids picking
on the other bowling kids that is um
bowling bully I know you're in it
together guys yeah that's like some
that's some weird infighting that
shouldn't happen you're both on the
bowling team you should stick
together you're going have to fight off
all kinds of
problems run faster
Jimmy I feel thank you for opening up
and chearing your your heartfelt and sad
bullying stories though I feel like if
you're on uh the bowling team you
probably have some pretty good like arm
though in one arm yeah in one arm yeah
but you know that's it's that's all you
need it's one arm to knock someone
out and I've never gotten into a fight
is there really no I gu I've never been
in a real fight there there was a fight
that happened right outside my locker uh
which was very inconvenient for me cuz I
needed to get to my locker guys guys I
got to get can you stop I got to get my
books I have to go to class imagine like
young Jean Luke being like guys I'm just
please oh yeah I was like a freshman and
I think it was like a couple Juniors or
seniors two girls who won oo I don't I
don't think anyone won there's a lot of
hair pulling which is like wait how what
are we doing c as many words okay uh
John luk I'm going to ignore you as I do
this I'm not sure I can actually like
that's fine people in the chat come to
me with your your question this okay so
here we go this is one all right
good oh it didn't let me do that what a
bummer I like this one uh Shane of the
Year says uh not really a bullying story
but one of my friends was walking down
the hallway by himself reading a book
intently and I snuck up behind him
slapped the book out of his hand and
word sorry nerd and ran off that's some
good like light-hearted friend
humor I had I had that like my friends
would like you know be dicks and and and
like pull my seat from under me you know
at the cafet area [__] like that yeah
sometimes your friends
are okay the biggest bullies mow well
done why did I accept that the first I
must have [__] it up somehow um hey
com me out here I'm I'm looking here
uh mole mole there you go that's a good
one good show yes M yes
low yeah we can crowdsource this I don't
have to think about this at all might
have enough time though uh we have
another 2 minutes of this an exciting
two minutes of our live stream is
devoted to uh War puzzles
uh I don't know why I'm so bad at
these oh thank you Caesar we we love you
too is wam a word probably not
no can't believe he didn't accept LOL
LOL I'm so disappointed I do this game
what 10 yeah I don't LOL is probably no
wait when this game come out what year
uh 2006 yeah LOL is a thing it totally
but it's also not a real word it it is
now it's in like the dictionary I think
someone said try LOL like I already did
man yeah see if he accepts meow oh meow
yeah is that I mean that's a word yeah
okay cool thanks chat do no there's no n
I was going to say like lemon lemon yeah
[Music]
H H you got mow yeah and Mo and
mo oh wait what about Mo just Moe what
about mify that's a name though yeah a
dictionary you're not a dictionary
jerk oh somebody posted a story uh we'll
get to that once we solve this puzzle
though we have 40 seconds come on chat
we're bad at this apparently oh I think
someone suggested wo which is a good one
I can't believe I didn't think of wo you
can't so full of
wo um 30 seconds guys we're only going
to get like a c or
something uh this is way harder than
chemistry chemistry was just like button
prompts yeah this one's tough but you
passed you did pass though you got
enough oh do I just have to pass that's
all I have to do well I think if you get
like all if you get like 100% you get
like a bonus for it but good
enough we're just going to we're going
to settle for passing listen we're only
streaming for an hour we can't can't be
bothered to uh we pride Leo I think just
a
name well done James yep all I had to do
is pass Anarchy F says I was a little Al
Punk girl in high school and had a
teacher who was a bully unless you were
a cheerleader or jock well that's
some teachers are dicks as as bully has
taught
us uh she had a problem with a friend of
mine one day and through her homework in
the trash so I stood up tossed my desk
over and yelled you're an evil effing
[__] and bailed damn wow how did that
work out for you yeah I'm kind of
curious how that ended but that's pretty
that's pretty awesome intense I'm kind
of into that it's like guys I got an
apology bonus Jimmy Hopkins
delivers really great progression system
you can apologize more effectively oh
this this sad this sad young man I can't
even help you I'm
sorry
understand and back I don't even know
where we're going I didn't even pay
attention to where we're supposed to go
next I'm just heading towards the way
marker man yeah I'm remembering all
these different like fun activities like
there's um there's a whole like uh class
president I believe bit where you had to
like help a kid get elected class
president yeah I'm pretty sure that
there's like like election fraud in this
game yeah you like tearing down posters
and like yeah beating people and making
them vote for
somebody that sounds right I don't think
that portion of my high school career
was like nobody took it that seriously
that I remember no like student
government was pretty much a joke yeah
you don't do anything in school no I'm
going to guess it looks good on like
college applications oh it definitely
does
absolutely unsurprisingly I was the
editor and chief of my high school paper
which is how I ended up here okay all
right sure I'll do it High School papers
are are hey man what's going on cool I
was telling P here about my IDE oh yeah
totally ours was pretty legit too like
we actually printed a like relatively
nice like physical newspaper every month
yeah we had one too it was very in I
came up with sounds right it's
sink my friend and if you're good at
swimming Middle School got let the
losers Dr at the end of every month had
like a program that would play on all
the TVs yeah we had that too and I
always thought it was the coolest thing
cuz they had like green screen you have
cameras yeah they wow and I remember
thinking at the time cuz I love video
you know
hey I'm a video produc I was like man I
really want to do that I was like oh
well like I guess I'm like I don't know
how to like I didn't know how to do that
like what to do to be involved in that
and like thinking about it now I'm like
I should have just like I could have
just gone up and like I knew the teacher
I
could could have but as a as a shy
Middle School I was like well I guess
I'm not I don't know whatever like don't
lie may have had some confidence issues
luk it worked out with me end though you
know doing video stuff for a living yeah
I feel I made I made it out pretty good
you're currently at work playing Bully
oh PD with all our our lovely uh twitch
and YouTube and site friends let's go
see how good you are with this the dark
KN says who hates Red Dead no one dude
red Dead's great I hear I'm super down
I'm excited about Red Dead too me too
yeah that game looks really rad you know
maybe someday we'll get a bully too but
for now I'm perfectly happy to Red Dead
better get a better get a bully
too someone on YouTube just wrote ah
pears was that for the word puzzle I
don't think there was a p in that
selection of letters oh whoops come back
Gary the stream isn't that far behind
Gary no
uh I'm also B we're probably never going
to get a Ellie Noir too cuz that was a
game that
was fight me D I would have loved to
have seen like what a sequel to that
game could have been like how do you
expanding upon those mechanics can I
help this kid I'm just going to punch
you hey okay now I'm going to run away
nope bye what if that kid will like
thank you though I feel like uh LA Noir
would have been a lot better if they
hadn't bothered with the open World
stuff like the investigations and all
that was really cool and really new and
interesting and the open world was like
oh you just kind of slap this on here
huh that game is basically uh a pointand
click adventure game with like an open
world you can drive around in there's
nothing to do and that's probably why I
like that game so much cuz I love uh
Point clck adventure games can't believe
I switched my meds again like you just
walk rounds you find objects you pick
them up you talk to people it's it's
totally what that game is it's
great G also just uh very brazenly rips
off the plot of LA Confidential oh yeah
but like I don't know LA Confidential in
in game form is I'm down I you know one
of my favorite movies LA Confidential so
it's not a bad thing and and they do it
they do enough differently that it
doesn't feel like I'm just watching LA
Confidential they they do mix some
things up
[Music]
it's got some chinat toown in it as well
anybody any Chinatown fans out there
it's Chinatown Jake man I'm oh this
music I am so into this you're just
going to go back to your desk and listen
to the soundtrack the rest of the day
yes oh this is a long commute we're so
far across the map this is I mean look
at how big the school is though like
we're in some totally
unrelated how I oh like the uh pool is
and then the now I'm fighting both these
guys you can be like um I think you do
like boxing or wrestling you do like
wrestling o that
hurt uh yeah there's a whole basketball
section from what I
remember y basketball wrestling oh I
just got shoulder tackles okay I'm going
to run from the football team bye
football team there's a whole thing
where you're like shooting eggs at
like this is bad out of this might this
might be the part I'm thinking of
actually where you like you like mess
with the m practicing
football we'll find out or no I'll have
to fight these guys before it lets me do
that okay hang
on Jimmy
no yeah these guys are uh these guys are
much tougher than my
last
o oh come on Camry get it
together you can do
it
let me grab you yeah oh yep good yes yep
punching more punching no okay no stay
locked on concentrate fire get one of
them down oh no oh no oh that was I
wasn't doing anything there that was
just
weird screw you football jocks I'll show
you this is for every swirly I got more
Cola which apparently is not actually a
weapon cuz like it's not in my inventory
you going to cry now oh we have an end
to that uh that story of the uh oh yes
Anarchy she said uh talked to a bunch of
the other students uh she was bullying
uh there were a lot and went to the
student advisor demand to be transferred
to other classes and explained why
principal notics what's going on and
there ended up being an investigation
apparently there were other things she
was up to because she wasn't there the
next year dang that worked out great
good for you calling her
out that's not the way I expected that
story to end at all
yeah new jet Angel brings up a good
point where he says Rockstar has a lot
of series that could go back to smoke
run man hunt state of emergency somehow
dat doubt they will go uh they will get
to these uh somehow I doubt those will
get new games which yes
um the only one I could see of those uh
he mentioned was Manhunt but
um even Manhunt feels very
like as a premise like I it's not that I
I'm like inherently against the idea of
Manhunt as a game I'm not like oh
Manhunt it's it's more that I don't know
what else you could do with that oh
Rockstar can find some things I actually
really enjoyed the The Manhunt games but
I think primarily because they were
among the earliest like true stealth
games that I played um cuz I really love
Metal Gear Solid it's still my favorite
series of all time and at the time I I
hadn't really played many other stealth
games and I found Manhunt and that can
most of that game can be played and is
actually better if you play it as a
stealth game so that's what I really
like about Manhunt it's really gruesome
though yeah it like surpasses Mortal
Kombat in terms of like messed up stuff
you can do that's kind of where I'm
going is like I think like it was so
messed up but I feel
like I don't know if they can really
push that any further the the messed up
part of
it let me down maybe stealth though who
knows go jimy go we got plenty of great
stealth games now though oh yeah I got
tons of options
now all right all the way
back well 7:00 p.m. time for bed hi to
you too Anarchy thank you for watching
we really appreciate it yeah uh I guess
we should say once again hello this is
Bully Scholarship Edition this is just
as of today now available as a backwards
compatible title so we're currently
playing on Xbox one even though this is
the 360 version Scholarship Edition um
but you you can go download it yourself
it is now backwards compatible
so I was just
thinking um I might finally get rid of
my Xbox uh 360 because all of the games
I own on that are pretty much now
backwards compatible on my Xbox one so I
was like man I cuz you only I'm I'm
always conflicted with like keeping game
stuff where part of me is like I should
keep all these games because everyone
want to play them the other part some
going to strike like I really need to
play Fallout 3 again or whatever yeah
but the other part of me is like and
then there's also like a nostalgist of
it of like having an old game console is
like kind of cool but at the same time
you know space and and clutter like
builds up you know and it's like well I
can't act I feel like I can't actually
so I think I could maybe get rid of my
360 finally because if I ever actually
want to play my 360 Xbox got it all now
I mean you know hats off and Microsoft
are making that happen they've done a
really great job of Shoring up their
compatibility uh
Library that's one in my mind like one
of the thing one of the areas where
Microsoft has very clearly done a better
job than Sony like there's a lot of
things that I think that the PS4 does
better but there's like no backwards
compatibility really um there are plenty
of old games available through PSN but
that doesn't help people who like own a
copy of a game on a disc and want to
play it I
mean on PSN on your if you if you pay
for it again you got to buy it again uh
which sucks but also it's not even the
scholarship enhanced Edition it's the
original PS2 version apologize not to
say it's a bad version of the game it
was the original version it's great but
forgive me like forget it that's kind of
crazy like that's the version they're
like yeah you can get this version and
you still have to buy it torment not
great really helpless and unfortunate
that homeless guy oh this is the one
kind of mean thing I don't like homeless
guy the way he treats the homeless guy
it's it's it's a little weird I mean
ultimately you're helping him but
littley it is a little weird I'm sorry
I'll give you it sucks cuz I I still
I'll probably keep my PS3 around for a
while because it has I have a lot of PS3
games that I am like I would love to go
back to that game eventually like if I
want to play Metal Gear I have to play
on my PS3 there's no way to like play
those older metal gear games on my PS4 I
don't think right uh yeah I don't this
is going to be fun I don't remember
which ones are available if any in PSN I
haven't really checked cuz yeah I still
I I own them all on dis and I still have
a PS3 so yeah exactly like I kind of
need to keep my PS3
which sort of
sucks are they following me are you guys
with me hey where are you yep yeah
they're
following this is my favorite music in
the game like the sneaky night time
music it's really good
Baseline what's this is that a colle no
Jimmy go there you
go pick up these sparkling apples Chad
how do I pick things there we go
yeah just hit buttons until it works a
lot of people in the chat talking very
nostalgic for Bully uh excuse Ray The
Dark Knight says it's greatest game ever
um I dude I'm with you like I love this
game if there's anything you guys want
to see specifically that we can do at
this stage in the game let us know I
mean it's pretty early on so we're kind
of just playing through but if there's
something you want to seeed but try and
try and do what we can for you guys why
is the fight music playing was somebody
fighting us it's not even fight it's
also still like Run music or Escape
music or okay well whatever cut scene
time whatever it was is over now
sorry that's some really intense barb
wire dirty old perv you know you're not
very nice Gary and you're a loser pety
one of life's
unfortunate you know I just realized
there's kind of like a weird almost like
big leowski dynamic between the three of
them your dad does Jimmy's kind of like
the dude and then uh Gary sort of um
leave this guy who Canon
yeah John Goodman character somebody in
chat will remember
and I'll kill you El Donnie yeah that's
a long story Donnie you got any liquor
no I'm 15 well what about jokes no then
why shouldn't I kill you all right then
tough guy kill
me so weird really good ultimatum there
call Bluff sty you got guts when I was
on that rig in career watching my
buddies get killed by Friendly Fire I
could have used somebody like you yeah
that's intense thanks but I fight
irreverence is ever unimpressed and I'll
show you some real moves classified
moves real special army stuff cool me a
part for my radio and I'll show you what
the Army taught me what like how to get
shot by your own side exactly that is
brutal what a brutal line hey remember
that time that your your friends and and
and comrades were killed let me joke
about that homeless guy that's so dang
yeah that's that's real that's real
weird all right part hunting time I'm
guessing I can't get through here I have
to go around right is there a way to
access a world map I feel bad I'm so
totally
clueless yep there we go I knew there
was a map hey come back a really small
map okay there we go what's going to say
uh no it's in that building so how do I
so I bet if you
go um here go yeah go this way I think
there's and yeah seemed like there was a
an opening or something you get
into this guys going to try to fight me
you never know right like sometimes they
do sometimes well apparently they're
cool with me everything's fine yeah here
we
are oh there it
is this is some sneaky spine
Angel says he was looking at the map
that came in the box and it's kind of
funny the school is bigger than most of
the town I'm trying to remember how big
the town was I mean the town is
definitely kind of it come you don't get
it till later you don't gain access to
it for a little while really so it's
just kind of there to like open up other
storytelling opportunities really most
the focus is on school so like I'm I'm
okay with that map design that makes
sense yeah I think the town
had like I had a lot of long winding
roads but it's definitely like the
school is more condensed with stuff I
remember kind of hating the bike races
at the time cuz they they were way
harder than they needed to be although
if you ended up out front and didn't
screw it up that's really all you needed
to do I struggled to think of any open
world game where I enjoy the racing that
isn't an open world racing game
specifically yeah you know I vehicle
stuff in games that aren't devoted to
Vehicles generally not spectacular like
ah camera horse racing and even Red Dead
I was like eh like I've just never into
that stuff at all I never find it
appealing thanks kid you're one of the
good
ones look I brought you this junk this
one from this crazy guy I sh with okay
he was my friend ah
uppercut heavy
attack I appreciate that he actually
stops talking when you punch him in the
face not like just totally scripted when
you come back yeah yeah so every time
you find one of those you can you learn
God that music is so good too like the
that's up there with the Final Fantasy 7
like like in my mind I like that music
is burned into my brain like The Legend
of Zelda you know you got an
item why are you fighting me what did I
do to you oh you're alone some Oh no
you're not alone okay I don't have time
for this run away oh there's a somebody
on my radar who wants oh it's a prefect
hey I'm not doing anything weeaboo
Supreme on YouTube actually uh really
like the B races weeaboo Supreme yeah
it's a good
name it's good man Own It Embrace
Embrace who you
are yeah yeah yeah he's mad that we were
we were calling out the bike races he
like he liked them yeah hey teach their
own I mean that's one of the cool things
about bully there's a lot going on what
why are you fighting me why I just want
to go to bed and apparently run into
this wall
endlessly I thought he was
gonna which would been really funny also
this is a sick room by the way my my
door room in college wasn't this nice
look at how big this is I was going to
say that's huge yeah that's
massive all right Save and Sleep we got
about I don't know about 10 15 minutes
left in the Stream so again if there's
anything you guys want to see in
particular uh that we could have access
to at this point in the game let us know
um like I said we we started from the
beginning of the campaign so we we knew
we weren't going to make it super far
this is mainly just little piece of
nostalgia but again if you missed it we
are playing Bully uh is now backwards
compatible so you can play it on your
Xbox one even if you
uh if you own a digital copy or if you
own a uh disc copy I think you can throw
it in your system disc copy throw it in
digital copy yeah thank you Microsoft
for making that possible and hopefully
someday we'll get a a bully too
someday okay I'm just going to go to bed
how do I oh wait oh you have to do it at
the that's dumb don't I like
select I don't know how to sleep guys
that's right Rockstar thing you have to
go to a specific thing to there I have
stand on this side of the
bed they can only make one they only
have time for one animation
yeah all right pajama time just going to
going to pajama It Up
pajam Wait do I have is it the weekend
Oh I get all kinds of that must be the
weekend cuz it's letting me do other
stuff you can like mix and match yeah
there we go oh yeah into
it but got to have shoes on of course
nah
nah nah we're good good to go perfect
all right this is where we're going with
this looking
sharp I wonder if people make fun of you
I don't
that yep they do there you
[Music]
go that's good good
reactiv this just yeah okay tutorial
stuff
Boop how's chat doing over there uh
Johnny Carlos says imagine if bully came
out today people would be complaining
that encourages bullying uh we don't
have to imagine that world where were
you 10 years ago Dude that very much did
happen when this game came out
absolutely I bet you if if I did own a
PS2 when this game came out and I tried
to buy this game my parents would
probably question it they might they
might they might actually let me if like
they saw the game cuz my parents are
actually pretty understanding about that
stuff but they definitely would have not
just like bought it without they would
have looked into it for
sure sorry I'm reading uh do you
remember bully is rated cuz I don't is
it teen I'm guessing te no it's
definitely teen yeah so you could have
bought it I mean it wasn't a mature
rated oh yeah but my parents would have
probably been like I would have like
been questioning about it I love the
confidence on his face despite the Tidy
whes so you're the new kid huh everyone
is talking about you oh are they and
what are they saying it's this whole
conversation in a new SP like he's like
looking down like uh I don't know how to
react to this Jimmy's pulling a real
power play right now with his no I know
just like looking you in the eyes like
yo what about my pants hey what are
people saying about me nothing to help
try
this returned but I'm scared to go to my
locker like a librarian man someone had
done that during game of the year
debates like stood up and be like let me
tell you about not having pants this
game and why it's so great and no one
would have argued with you no two bucks
great five bucks let's go buddy some
hard negotiating right there really
again just like the pantsless adds to
Ramsey the bestore legit great name says
I'm playing Bully on my phone uh how is
it I'm I'm actually curious how the iOS
Port I almost can't imagine like not
playing this with a
Gamepad I know it has that like on
screen you know controller sck thing
that I think just sucks like I I've
never found that to be fun and you know
a lot of the screen real estate is taken
up by it and it just looks awful but I
heard I'm curious if wow that dud not
bad or
not fight fight have have you ever seen
the mobile Port of Resident Evil 4 it's
it is I really have to quite bad yeah
I've actually that one I think is
notoriously bad
Alon come on I mean resent evil has um a
couple notorious the original PC Port of
resent Evil 4 is also notoriously bad it
didn't even offer any Mouse controls
whatsoever this is the worst I just want
to go to class like if you played that
game with a keyboard um you had to use
the arrow keys to
aim it was functionally like o that was
bad it was
terrible yeah wedgie oh didn't get a
good view Fatal Frame say uh sorry fatal
metal says Hey gam spot how you doing
not bad Fatal Frame there's a game Fatal
Frame Alon get it
together yeah um not bad kind of we're
winding down well you're sick I'm sick
everyone else is sick yep from that
though uh everything's winding down
we're kind of wrapping up our our uh
there it is all of our game of the year
content yeah you should be checking the
site we've got a lot of game of the year
stuff going up every day or best of cuz
we're we're covering a whole bunch of
stuff this year yep um we'll be
announcing the top five on yeah best PS4
games just went up today our top 25 list
starts posting tomorrow so like entries
number 25 to 21 will'll post tomorrow
and there's going to be another five
every day until Tuesday ah and then on
Tuesday we're going to be doing a live
stream where we're going to do the top
uh top five top five every every hour
they're going to uh play the video uh
play the top five video and then they're
going to play the game for an hour on
the stream and they're going to do it
for uh
for all five damn you were busted which
that's pretty cool I'm not going to be
here for that unfortunately I'm leaving
a week early um but I'm I definitely am
going to like uh check that out um at
home just like you all should like
everyone else here should
do oh I was going to class anyway all
right yeah if you get busted they just
make you out class my pleasure to induct
you into the world of Arts I think I
maybe failed I probably have to repeat
the mission where I escort algae to
class but we're not going to be on
stream at that point anyway so going to
do some art we're going to do some art
and then probably call it the day on the
stream Neo J Angel says it on Monday no
it is on Tuesday yeah so the top five
live stream is on Tuesday and every day
starting tomorrow we're going to do five
so tomorrow is 25 to 21 on the list so
on and so forth all the way to Tuesday
Tuesday is the top five and we'll have a
live stream and a bunch of promo stuff
so check it out we'll if you visit the
site you will see all of that so we
encourage you to come back although we
have some uh preliminary Game of the
Year stuff already up like some year in
year in review um all of the platforms
are like individual writeups for for
platforms I think are they all up now
they're all up now as of PS4 yes yes yes
PS4 came out this morning Xbox PC 3DS
even like expansions and reissues got
their own VR got own this year so a lot
of lot of stuff already on the site for
you guys to check out her Baler 69 says
my money's on Doom for Game of the Year
obviously we can't say anything you know
long the mystery but I will say that uh
Doom was on my personal my personal game
of the year
um but that does that does not give
anything away cuz uh my personal opinion
uh does not really matter much in the
collective game spots um but we are also
putting up a um personal top T that
comes a little later though uh that's
there's going to be list that goes up
with those so you will get to see
everyone else's personal top 10
basically any possible version of a best
of we're doing something for it but the
big one the top 25 is going to be five a
day St that's an old school I think cuz
I've completed three class I think that
was for completing classes I could be
wrong I don't know oh and I haven't even
met Mr Gym coach guy yet
hi this is awkward I got you these
flowers oh Jimmy that's so nice of you
why everyone's really hot or cold in
this game they either want to fight him
or they'll make out with
him the no pants thing helps he's very
short oh man leg that is some intense uh
leg up wow wow jeez get a room my God
it's like take it easy kids in the
hallway do you think anyone saw well you
were standing in the middle of a
school I I didn't spend much time going
I'm awesome and fist pumping in in high
school I don't know about you no no
definitely not uh especially not after
making out with
somebody Bor oh oh this is bad hey okay
never mind ha just kidding
bye bye hi there's a down arrow so oh
I'm on the second floor that's why oh hi
I thought I was on the ground floor
apparently Art's on the second floor
guys Scotty law says good oh uh don't
know if they're working on a sequel
since the composer ratted them out I'm
not familiar with what that's about I
don't know what that's in reference
to let us know person who said that also
what's a good wait what's a good finale
for this stream like how do we wrap this
up cuz it's story driven game that we
can't just like steal a car and drive it
off a ramp it's kind of just like it's
over but that's so anti-climatic we got
to find a way we got to do something we
got to wrap this what if you try and see
how many people can get to chase you
like a like on a
line where are the bullies let me find
find people that'll fight me you got to
punch someone those guys hey these guys
will fight me hey what's
up oh you're R away oh no the prefix
never mind this went horribly wrong okay
I'm going to run I'm going to run from
that guy grab his nipples might have
there he's going to chase me
though hey you hey you fight
me I'm not really worried about class
right now game play some not really
after you okay they are I'm going to
sneak I'm going to sneak he'll never
find me ah no he found me I lied I think
I'm busted now
yep W yeah definitely this game doesn't
have quite the sandbox nature that like
um pretty I mean on yeah it's a pretty
guided
experience you brought gym class on
yourself right wh it's time for some
wrestling maybe after the wrestling R
yeah I'll I'll uh I'll wrestle this this
strange en blob of a of a man and then
we will call it a day Rams the best
legit says use mods uh I'm not familiar
with uh much of the mod scene for this
game but um I mean obviously we're
playing on Xbox so we definitely can't I
don't think that was a legal
move on PC there there might be mods
that is
soer I'm going to die like her was like
swooning so dangerous oh my god oh
dangerous you're out of the ring this is
super not how wrestling works you
supposed
to why am I such a doofus that's why
Hopkins get closer oh yeah did anybody
ever weigh in with their favorite
juvenile insults I think fart bag was uh
was number one doist is a classic but
not all that creative I didn't I didn't
I didn't see any what I was looking
might have missed
them everyone weigh in last second with
your favorite Chile insults so far I'm
thinking far bag's going to take it home
heart bag's a good one I'm going to
punch you into the
cheerleaders
aha soad oh apparently I pushed him far
oh stay stay on the mat okay fine all
right
my tender soul my tender Soul that's
such a good line oh I shall the uh yeah
Ramsey the best says there are mods on
PC version of this game I'm curious what
those are are they like just graphical
mods are there are there more um
gameplay changes that'd be kind of
interesting you need straight A's you
just hack your
grades I passed
JY this like random surf like
yeah we've been beamed into that thing
you do when you pass a class yeah that
is kind of out of place but it totally
works works for me I love it all right
that's probably uh a good place to call
it uh cuz you know we can't that's
that's as much of a finale as we can do
beating up a kid in gym class really the
most appropriate way to end a stream of
a game called bully which is now
available it's a backwards compatible
title on Xbox way to go Microsoft you
know how much it costs if you wanted to
buy on 15 bucks 15 bucks buy digitally
yeah and you'll still see it'll still
show up as the 360 version like it'll
say you're buying a 360 game but it'll
appear in you're ready to ready to
download tab on your Xbox one yeah as
long as you're buying it on the same
account like blah blah blah you you guys
know it works you've bought games before
um yeah thanks for tuning in to our
stream of bully uh tune in for more live
streams I think I think we have another
one do we have another stream coming up
today I don't know about
today I honest they don't know certainly
next week again a lot of our game of the
year stuff is happening right now so if
nothing else tune in next Tuesday for
our big 5H hour live stream where we
will reveal our top five overall games
of the year going to be on that as
chosen by the Gamespot staff I will yes
I will be on that Mary Kish will be on
that I know what part you're GNA be on
yeah we can't spoil anything here but
yeah I will be on Mary Kish will be on I
think Rob Handler at some point uh Peter
Brown our reviews editor like most most
the staff who was still here in the
office prior to the holiday break will
be on that Stream So yeah thank thank
you guys so much for tuning in today and
like watching us play a little bit of
bully uh sorry we couldn't get a little
bit further into the game but hopefully
got a taste and kind of remember what
this game's all about and thank you for
sharing your traumatic High School
stories with us yes very appreciated uh
for now though I think that's going to
do it so thanks thanks again for tuning
in come back next Tuesday for Game of
the Year stuff and uh keep it tuned to
gamespot.com for all of your video game
needs
[Music]
bye people my work here is done our work
here is done guys our work here is
done